funny enough when I when I started
reading the book when I started talking
to David I read the first section of the
book and I said I don't know that I'm
right for this girl because I I feel I'm
being asked strongly to like this
character and I've I don't quite buy her
you know because you meet at the
beginning the diary Amy who's this sort
of you know woman who you know tolerates
every sort of screw-up by her guy you
know he comes in drunk at 3:00 in the
morning he's got body glitter maybe been
with a stripper she's like come to bed
baby let me give you a [ __ ] and it's
um
and I'm like I'm not sure I feel that
there's a sort of version of femininity
I don't quite buy it's it's and then
sure enough the book changes and you get
her real voice and suddenly I felt I
could relax because you know I felt I'd
got something honest out of her I mean I
do I feel I understand her for whatever
in whatever you know dark place that
puts me but you know I I kind of related
to or felt I could understand this this
girl who's grown up with you know to
sort of pressed gently pressurizing
parents not the sort of alpha parents
who are forcing her to do this and that
they're the sort of the seemingly caring
parents who inadvertently you know give
their child a recipe for narcissism in
in creating this fictional sibling for
her amazing Amy you know who's a sort of
sweet cartoon but one who's always
better than her more accomplished than
her succeeds every time real Amy fails
and and so I think you've got this
little girl who grows up with a with a
sort of Fame she never earned and is
made to be the face of this cartoon and
so similarly taneous he feels entitled
and really insecure and I sort of think
well where does that little girl what
does that little girl turn into when she
becomes an adult and she's on the dating
scene and and and and she's so at ease
with sort of putting on appearances that
she can just sort of shape-shift and and
and be whatever's require
by the situation and it's really unreal
axing it's a very you know I see Carrie
Coons amazing performances go and I I
think God if Amy could have just sort of
been that sort of woman who could be
authentically relentlessly herself at
every moment she'd have had a much
better ride but Amy's always scanning
herself and scanning everybody she meets
and and it's really exhausting it's all
I can that's the only way I can put it
really that was a long answer was no was
that it was terrific
he also the line that he says to the
parents at the press conference towards
the end when he says you must be so
proud it seems like a throwaway but it
actually really Stu what you're talking
about that and then Ben Affleck met my
mother in the lift at the premiere and
said you must be so proud my mother
sweetie went oh well thank you so much I
said watch it I said wait till you see
the movie before you kind of has like
been that was really mean there is a I
feel like there's a sympathetic side
obviously to Amy though and the moment
that that strikes me as sympathetic
early on in the flashbacks is when she
says when you say to Ben why are you
pushing me to be someone I don't want to
be there's almost a sense of she could
have sustained at least some sort of
level of psychic of psychic even-keeled
ness if she hadn't been pushed in the
wrong situation or so do you see that
that's such an interesting question you
see you ask you all the questions that
now with us that I've been thinking
about too um because a lot of people who
read the book really latched on to this
notion of the cool girl and playing the
cool girl that's that that idea that
that I think it resonated with men
because everyone thinks god I had a
girlfriend in college who was like that
and she was great for like three weeks
and then suddenly it all changed or
whatever and and women have a set of
guilty identification because I mean uh
it's not all sinister part of it so
growing up process trying on different
guises and but one thing that seems to
be missed
is that Amy says when she does in the
voice-over actually she says you know
and it was really fun being someone else
we were really happy pretending to be
these people we weren't we weren't
really and I think that with that
pretense comes a sort of freedom and an
ease you know she's a sort of lighter
more happy-go-lucky person than that
rubs off I mean I think this sort of
narcissistic projection is is what
really fascinates me about these
characters and and you know Amy needs
her partner to be exemplary and Nick is
fully capable of that and so when you
see him on TV and he's doing his
performance on Sharon she where she
doesn't care that it's a performance she
knows it's a performance but it's what
she wants you know she wants that guy
who can would be winning charming and an
esteem her you know love her in the way
she wants even if it's even if it's not
real she will take that that's the sort
of I suppose that's what the narcissist
demands
it kind of helping him find the best of
himself in a way even though it's her
version of the best it's still a best of
himself as opposed to the worst of
himself or some sort of shadow yes I
mean the you know the guy she doesn't
want she doesn't feel like the girl who
deserves you know she's intolerant she's
got um she's got unrealistically high
expectations that everyone is bound to
fail we see her other relationships in
the past and you know the Nick who sits
around his boxers playing video games
that's not eating Chinese food that's
not who she wants it started it was Rick
the first day of shooting was was the
scenes by the swimming pool in the
Ozarks and coming out of her cabin when
she's just deciding who Nancy this
figure is and it was unbelievably
difficult because and disorienting and
because you haven't I hadn't played real
Amy who ever real Amy as you know I
hadn't and and it it and what was so
hard at the beginning became the most
fun you know by the time we got back to
that stuff and we're in the studio and
we're inside the cabin doing all the
sort of spitting in the drink stuff and
you know watching Ellen Abbott on TV and
sort of seeing the plan come to fruition
it was really fun because I could enjoy
knowing I had Amy's brain just there and
then playing something else for the
other girl in the room but it was
unbelievably difficult that to start
with
I probably shouldn't admit things like
that but it's so I will did it was very
you know you it's hard to get a grasp on
do you have you experienced men and
women watching this movie in different
ways and reacting in different ways to
it
I heard reports of you tonight of
different reactions from men and women I
didn't I mean I know there are certain
points like when Nick's girlfriend comes
into it you know the men in the audience
quite often to the city and the and the
women sort of sit back I've seen that
happen and I've had men say that they
identify with Amy - I think it is it is
about the male/female experience this
film a lot but then and I think what's
David has done so brilliantly is you
know you start off watching a film you
know it's sort of procedural and and you
know it's it's it's this this this idea
of you know the missing wife and and you
know well it must be the husband because
we've seen that so many times and and
you're watching these two characters and
all the other surrounding characters and
and then suddenly it gets towards the
end of the movie in and you start
thinking will actually hang on this is
sort of about me and people I know and
it's not sort of them anymore it's it
turns into a satire in that respect how
first were you in David's films and
Pinterest films before this one had you
I mean you guys I'm sure you had seen
many of them did you know what to expect
I do you know I don't know if I knew
what to expect from I remember having a
conversation with Jake Gyllenhaal years
ago while he was shooting zodiac and
hearing about the sort of intensity of
the work and how exhausting it was and I
remember thinking god I wish I could do
something like that I wish I could work
like that you know because that you you
know the habitual experience is usually
being not you know of something having
to move on before you're satisfied you
feel it explored anything or you go home
and think ah why didn't I think of that
or why didn't I do it like that and when
you're working with David it's so odd
you don't you don't really have those
moments because he gives he gives you
the gift of time
to explore and you might think you know
I could have you often think you know
the bar set so high I'm never going to
achieve he sort of shows you a level of
excellence that you sort of aspire to
and sometimes just think I'm going to
forever fall short of but but but you
don't think I didn't try it
I didn't explore it I often here I often
think every scene of in his films could
almost be a small film in and of itself
it's really true because the the detail
that he puts into it you know he's he
knows what has to happen in each scene
and and and it's so dense and layered
and you know it's when you hear the
voice over in Edward Norton and Fight
Club it penetrates into your skull you
feel you're hearing so much more than
just the words and now I've worked on
voiceover with him I see you why it's
because we spend days doing it days and
days it's all been so heady and and
giddy and and the idea that this
director who you've watched all of his
movies has watched any of yours is is is
really extraordinary and I heard that
David Fincher wanted to talk to about
something I didn't know what it was and
then I heard it was this book and I
hadn't read it which was probably a good
thing because as I said I got let expire
got to monitor that experience that
experience of me saying I don't think I
quite buy this girl into oh I suddenly
see where this characters going you know
everyone knows he's got a very singular
approach to casting and I know how you
know how incredibly lucky I am that this
just that that I was the idea that
peaked in his brain and made sense to
him you know so I can't say that in a
sort of fair trial that if we'd all you
know a whole lot of actresses had read
these scenes that I would have read them
any better than anyone else I mean that
is not the case it's just it's luck in
his mind it's inked but yes I think he
wanted to see if I had the guts and the
sort of lack of vanity and you know he
said okay he said if we do this you know
amy has to gain weight and lose weight
and I said okay that's fine he said I
said what like 12 pounds or something
that's what it is in the book he said
but we're gonna have to do that three
times over because of the schedule so
you're going to have to gain it lose it
gain it lose it gain it lose it so I
said you know turn my body into a kind
of chemistry lab and
and he said yeah I was 100 days right
though yeah so and he said we've built
in about 10 days each time to accomplish
it and you sort of find yourself saying
yeah yeah yeah I can yeah no prob I can
note I can do that no problem then it's
it's harder than I mean it is hard it's
it's it you know and I thought I can do
this in a so skillful way and actually
it just came down to stuffing my face
with donuts and B not doing anything and
then eating very little and running
three hours a day I mean it was sort of
it's a schizophrenic yo-yoing um
what a crazy mindset right there is just
to be able to well I think that might
have been the idea I'm sure it wasn't
that maybe it wasn't even necessary they
could I just give which has done it with
clever effects so maybe that was the
whole idea he wanted to sort of
destabilize me